البدايه من الاراضي الفلسطينيه حيث استشهد
شاب برصاص الاحتلال الاسرائيلي قرب بلده
السنجل شمالي رام الله بالضفه الغربيه
وقالت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه في بيانها
ان الشاب مصعب نفل وصل الى مجمع فلسطين
الطبي برام رام الله مصابا برصاصه في
القلب حيث وصفت اصابته بالحرجه واضفت
الوزاره ان تواقيم الاسعاف حاولت انعاشه
دون جدوى واعلنت استشهاده متاثرا بجروحه
التي اصيب بها قرب البلده وكان المتحدث
باسم الجيش الاسرائيليه كذا ان قوه من
الجيش اطلقت الرصاصه على الفلسطينيين
رشققها مركبات المستوطنين بالحجاره قرب
بلده سنجل الشمالي رام الله وقتلت احدهما
واصابه الاخره واعتقالته
كما اصيب شاب فلسطيني اخر برصاص الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي خلال مواجهات اندلعت قرب حاجز
بيت ايل العسكري شمال مدينه البيره بالضفه
الغربيه عقب تظاهره خرجت من جامعه بيرزيت
للتنديد بجرائم الاحتلال وكان طلبه جامعه
بيرزيت نظموا جنازه رمزيه لزميلهم الشهيد
عامر حلبيه منفذ عمليه الطعن في القدس
المحتله قبل يومين وردد طلبه تافات تدين
تصعيد الاسرائيليه في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
كما تطالب بالوحده في مواجهه الاحتلال
ومستوطنيه